hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today i am
reviewing a website one of my Fiverr
gigs this is from ben wang and he runs
can i pay less calm i'm going to check
it out and see what kind of advice I can
give him so this is the site at first
glance i can understand what they're
doing here so credit cards are confusion
we're here to help so the tools to
maximize rebates find the card to fit
the lifestyle compare your cards to the
best on the market it's a nice design
you know looks professional I don't know
how much this character ties me to
credit cards and in the woods but that
that might be a little stronger with
branding and just to help people
understand what it is you do better but
the site design looks nice the idea here
I guess is you could put in how much
you're spending on different categories
and it recommends tools for you here
different credit cards I guess to apply
for and that's that's it that's a simple
page so if I'm spending I guess this
amount on these different tools these
are the different credit cards that can
apply for I can click let's see apply
now and it's great that it takes me
right to this website to be able to
apply for and let's see if I change
around my recommend how my budget see if
that changes so the credit cards are
still the same when if I make it a lot
bigger then there's one that shows up so
I'm not seeing a big variety let's say I
spend a lot on restaurants some changes
it doesn't seem to have a lot of credit
card options
but I could be wrong it still seems to
be the same kind of ones popping up over
and over again so that the obviously
then the business like this the way you
make money is you get up you get paid
for every credit card sign-up the danger
here is your only recommending the
credit cards that make you money instead
of actually help your customers and so
that's that's a people will be skeptical
and you want to maybe list all of the
credit cards that you do currently help
people browse through if you really want
to add a lot of value to people you'd
say we help you sort through you know
200 credit cards and find the one that's
best for you something like that could
help I'd also love to see some kind of
testimonials on here to have people say
yeah I use can I pay less and I saved
you know whatever or earn extra reward
because it was you know awesome service
but it's good that it kind of adjust
with some of the spending and it is easy
to sign up for card one thing I would
have and I don't save here but the
option to pick your bank so for example
i bank at TD all my counselor at TD on
my credit cards are TD I wouldn't go to
a Scotia account because it's just so
easy to pay off my TD bill with my TD
credit card at my TD bank online so I
wouldn't move to another bank for that
reason so it'd be great to be able to
say you know you select TD cards for
example and then go through the same
calculation help me pick the one that's
best for me but overall it's pretty good
there's some social media links here
let's see what happens when we click on
these so it's going to Facebook take in
a while oh this is just a share it ok so
I would love to see that you have some
of your own social media links for
people to actually connect with you if
they want to again adds more proof there
is a little more about the website so
let's check out the about us
press and blog page and see what what
shows up about us it's great to see
pictures it's awesome to see them
smiling happy faces easy to get in touch
with by email or a linkedin here maybe
want a little bit more of the story how
you guys started and why you're really
passionate about it this seems to be
more of a kind of corporate overview but
for the founders are especially Benson
here was the founder I guess you know
why are you passionate about this
business and how it can help people we
could to learn a little bit more about
that press kit uh it's pretty thin
you're not going to get reporters really
looking at this one press release on
april 9th and it is what june twelfth
now so we're two months in and you'd
want more information here there's not a
lot for reporters that go on here so i
can update that and then kind of payless
blog it's great to have a blog the
challenge is keeping it up-to-date so
you've got a long blog post here it's
great show some value of using it that's
awesome as was main ninth so again we're
june twelfth over a month has gone by we
haven't updated the blog it is a
commitment to have a blog on the website
and keep it updated keep it current so I
either make the decision to go with this
blog and and put something in there at
least every two weeks or take it off the
side of its not going to add value to
you or at least take off the date so you
can't see when it was posted and people
come to the page and think that it's
really outdated so April nineteenth and
may 9th were the only two blog posts but
overall I think it's a cool service I
think it could add a lot of value for
people again my skepticism is coming in
thinking that you're only promoting the
car is that and that you know you want
to promote instead of actually and a lot
of value so showing me all the list of
the cards that you do sort through could
be very helpful and it is great to see
how much you can save it's a pretty cool
tool pretty easy to use
so I like it I like it good work well
done for those of you watching if you
liked this video please give it a thumbs
up below I always love seeing those come
in and if you have a comment about this
video or question for your own business
feel free to leave it in the comment
section below I always read those and I
love seeing them so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode
you